des dab distributeur automatique de
billets ont été détruits à vesoul lure
et aussi dans des villes plus petites
comme pm dampierre haut-jussé
des explosions spectaculaires qui ont
marqué les esprits celui de saint
sauveur situé juste à côté de la mairie
a sauté le 5 août 2015 en pleine nuit et
il a beaucoup manqué aux habitants on a
une population quand même qui a du mal à
se déplacer qui est pas forcément
véhiculer et qui est bien comment qui
venait un soda et une population de
passage aussi qui s'arrêtait une autre
distributeur automatique était connu
dans notre secteur et il était très bien
fréquentée depuis en ont un nouveau
distributeur a été installé il se veut
manquer beaucoup
parce que nous étions obligés de se
rendre en ville pour recréer de l'argent
en espèces elle ça posait le problème de
stationnement
la mairie a dû participer financièrement
à cette installation car les
responsables de la banque
échaudé par les explosions distributeurs
étaient réticents il est très utile je
pense pour eux financièrement donc ils
sont venus près nous et puis ben nous on
a aussi pensé aux habitants
on a dit bombay allez il faut qu'on se
lance tant pis ça va nous côté un peu
d'argent mais il faut qu'on se lance et
là il s'est plus sécurisé ça coûte et
combien l'amérique
ça a coûté 15 1067 je crois ttc les
commerçants eux aussi avaient souffert
du manque de distributeurs automatiques
de billets il avait dû s'adapter
les petits achats quand vous achetez un
journal quand vous lâche t il faut bien
peu de débilité ont les cartes
bien sûr nous on donne on prend la carte
mais pas de minimum justement c'est venu
à cause du manque de dabola +2 minimum
donc on en a qui nous payent une
baguette à kaka dab et commerces
un duo gagnant ici à corbeny le dap se
trouve dans la zone commerciale située à
l'entrée de la commune est loin du
centre du village le maire le regrette
amèrement les personnes qui viennent
retirer de l'argent
quatre fortes chances qu'elle pour le
dépenser sur place d'au moins une partie
donc voilà il retire de l'argent aux dab
et puis la commission dans la zone
commerciale pourrait tirer de l'argent
général il reste des raisons
commerciales
ils vont pas perdre aux courses
l'association des maires ruraux de haute
saône se bat pour sauver ou implanter
des dab les commerces écoles postes sont
autant d'atouts pour dynamiser les
campagnes et les distributeurs sont
aussi à leur manière presque aussi utile
que les services publics